(audience murmuring)
- So, my name is Anup Nair.
I am the CTO for Mphasis AI.
And this is Bharat.
- I'm Bharat, senior
partner in Mphasis.ai.
- So, we are gonna talk
about legacy modernization
and Mphasis framework,
agentic AI framework
for legacy modernization.
That's what we are gonna talk about.
We have some exciting demos
as well as part of this thing.
So, I'm hoping you'll like it.
And if you have any questions,
please feel free to get us offline.
I don't think they
allow us questions here,
but yeah, why not, right?
So, to start off with,
let me give a little
background here, right?
Let's discuss the problem statement first.
I've, in the last 25 years,
every CIO I have met,
this is the problem: "I
can't innovate fast enough
because it's too risky to
touch any legacy platform."
Are you guys on the same
page when it comes to this?
In fact, one of the CIOs actually told me
that I have 49 core systems that are built
on COBOL mainframes, and
if I touch one of them,
I will touch all the remaining 48 as well.
So, this is the problem
we decided to solve.
Mphasis.ai has built
many different agentic AI
solutions to solve these problems.
So, Mphasis has an experience building
and modernizing legacy
application for many years.
So, we are gonna talk about this,
but more importantly,
I think I wanna double click
on the problem a little bit
more to really understand
the genesis of our solution.
Really describe the solution itself.
So, you know, the problem
with legacy system
is that enterprises, you know,
are anchored on these systems for years.
And, these systems have code,
business logic embedded
inside code for years, right?
And, every time you want to do something,
you need engineers, right?
You add business logic, this is in COBOL,
this is in Java, or it could
be Natural or Natural Adabas
or it could be Assembler
for that matter, right?
It could be all of those kind of system.
But you need specialist
engineers to handle this.
These engineers are not easily available.
They're not in the market, they're out
of the workforce at this point in time.
Therefore, you start
reinventing the wheel,
keep reinventing the
wheel on an ongoing basis,
and you start creating
a lot of technical debt.
Now, any change is too costly
because you're doing it
at 10 different places
and you're connecting,
creating layers and layers
and layers to solve the problem
because you don't know
what's actually going on.
So, now you think about this
and you decide to put AI on
top of it, agentic AI, right?
You're driving innovation.
You need to put agents, right?
Whether it is agents around claims
or agents around underwriting,
or whichever agent, you wanna
put agents on top of this.
Think how it is gonna be,
because all of these legacy systems
are so deeply monolithic, it
is extremely hard for any agent
to give you any productivity.
So, all your agentic AI objectives
and goals goes for a toss
just because you have this.
This is the reason why modernization.
This is the reason why
any innovation is so slow,
because you have to touch
everything out there.
So, at Mphasis, we thought about this
and we said, okay, you
know, it is really not just
about technical modernization.
It's not just modernizing COBOL to Java
or Natural to Java or
C++ to something new.
That is not the point.
It's about taking the intelligence
out of the legacy systems and
converting that into data.
That should be the goal, as
opposed to just modernizing
code from A to B.
That is exactly the
approach we have taken.
So, let me talk a little bit more
on how we are about to solve this thing.
But for that, how do
you typically modernize?
Are you aligned to this, everyone?
First you'll relearn
from your legacy systems,
then you reimagine,
then you re-architect, and then you recode
and then you start running it.
This is how you do, you take COBOL
and you convert it into Java
and you start managing it again.
In about three years' time,
that becomes legacy again.
This is how you typically do it, right?
So, what we have done is
slightly different approach here.
We've built agent AI agents,
AI agents that are autonomous
and semi-autonomous
with human in the loop.
Because anybody who says
that everything is 100%
autonomous is joking.
It's not. Okay?
So, we took documents
and code, we built an
agent called NeoZeta.
And, this agent actually reads everything,
converts everything into
human-understandable knowledge.
How do you do that?
We use domain knowledge,
Mphasis domain knowledge
to really make that happen
because we have encoded them.
We create a knowledge graph.
And then we thought, okay,
now we have a knowledge graph.
How do you take this
and create a new system?
What do you do? You generate
user stories out of it.
So, we created another
agent, we call it NeoSaba.
This agent takes everything
that you've learned,
converts into user stories
and focuses on governance,
focuses on compliance,
focuses on processes, business processes.
Saba stands for semi-autonomous
business analyst.
We take that and we allow a
business analyst to work on it.
We then convert whatever
we create out of this,
we put it back
into the knowledge graph.
Now, what's next step?
You re-architect. We've
created another agent.
we called it NeoRaina.
This is a agent that will
take everything you've learned
and helps you define the
target state architecture.
This target state
architecture is customizable
for you, for the client.
And, everything you
create out of this aligns
to enterprise standards.
The reason why it's customizable
is because you need to
make sure that it aligns
to enterprise standards.
Okay?
So, once you create that,
then all the architecture is done.
You take that and you rewrite.
We've created an agent called NeoCrux,
which takes everything,
allows you to prompt,
it uses whatever coding agent
is available in your enterprise
and starts writing code out of it.
Continuation to ops as
well, right? Why not?
You've built everything,
you put into production,
you've tested it through Crux and all.
Now you're putting into production,
you run operations as well.
But, all through this we've
built a connective tissue.
We've extracted the intelligence
out of the whole thing,
and created an enterprise knowledge graph.
That enterprise knowledge
graph is not just a database.
Knowledge graph's a database,
but this is not just a database.
It has meaning, it has enterprise meaning
because it is connected to your domain.
We call it Ontosphere.
And then we used a layer on top of it
to orchestrate the whole
thing so that we can get it
as autonomous as possible.
So, this is Mphasis'
approach to modernization.
Now, you will see some
of them are autonomous,
some of them are semi-autonomous.
As AI progresses, as
context abilities grow,
this will become more and more autonomous.
And, essentially you create a live
intelligence of the enterprise.
So, what you are going
to see today as a demo,
you're gonna see NeoZeta
extracting intelligence out of code.
You're gonna see NeoSaba
allowing the business user
to create user stories.
You're gonna see NeoRaina,
you are gonna see NewCrux
and you're not gonna see AI ops
because we didn't have enough time.
But you're gonna see a
glimpse of Ontosphere as well.
So, you're gonna see
five things, Zeta, Saba,
Raina, Crux and Ontosphere.
Okay?
So, I'm gonna switch to a demo
and let Bharat walk you
through a whole suit of things.
Bharat.
- So, let me start with first
talking about Ontosphere
because this is where the heart
of the information lies, right?
Every knowledge in the
system, whether it is code
or document, is gonna be brought
into as data on the on sphere.
Now, we are using a couple
of domain ontologies
which have been built
up, which is, you know,
on the financial industry,
insurance and other industries.
We have also kind of
really put in a couple
of engineering ontologies,
which is through our agents.
Okay?
This is the basis on which a lot
of modeling will be done into the system.
Let me go to the first
agent. So, this is NeoZeta.
As you see, NeoZeta,
I've selected a program,
I've selected a capability,
and we took a very complex
capability in terms
of the post-trade processing because this
is where you have a process
which stops at 4:00.
You have maybe millions of
trades which have to be processed
and files have to be sent
to the federal authorities.
So, we took this problem,
we said that the only way
that we will be able to
solve this is pick up a lot
of intelligence from
each of these processes,
which have been coded in legacy COBOL.
This is an example of COBOL
that we are showing you,
and then reverse engineer it
and post that help to kind of
really modernize it using our agents
onto a Flink based architecture.
And I'll show you a glimpse
of how did we execute it
on A CPU, as well as on A GPU,
how the performance varies.
So, continuing with our demo,
I've selected the capability.
I have capability to upload my files,
which may be documents, which
may be different assets.
I've uploaded COBOL copy books,
and I've also uploaded, as you see,
a domain model out here.
So, these are the programs that you see,
and this is the domain
model that I've uploaded.
Using the relearn agent,
I'm actually relearning
each and every program
or an entire capability.
So, as you see, I've actually
selected a program which
is Quantiles, along with copy books,
and I'm doing a reverse
engineering of it, right?
So, what it does is it has capabilities
to generate the data dictionary.
Now, we haven't fed any information,
but you see that there's a
good amount of information
that it has brought out from the system,
and it's starting to map it
with the actual functional attributes.
And I'm also showing you the
document that it produces.
The document has a certain
format, it produces summary.
Then, for each and every business rule,
it'll start providing me
a lot of data elements,
as you would see, right?
It'll gimme the logic,
it'll gimme the input,
it'll gimme the data
effect, it'll give me a lot
of other processing elements
that I would need as part
of relearning a certain code.
Now, the most important
piece is how do you verify
that the system has
done it very accurately.
So, we've introduced,
what is an LLM as a judge,
and it gives me a confidence
score for every rule
that has been reverse engineered.
As you see, it tells
me that one of the rule
has got an average coverage, which is 85%.
For us, 85% is average.
Anything about 95% is something
which we kind of counted as a better one.
But it tells me there is a human
in the loop interface over here.
I can go and make, you
know, corrections over here.
The first 100,000 lines
of code typically need such corrections.
But then for the next
million lines of code,
it's an automated way
where you get 95% accuracy
from the relearn agent.
So, we've produced data
dictionary, we've produced
business rules, and you've
seen the business rules
verification as well.
The third part is to convert
everything onto the Ontosphere,
which is the knowledge graph
and which is what, let me
demonstrate that to you.
It's just showing you
some of the attributes
from LLM as a judge.
So, I'll go to the
knowledge graph right now.
Actually, before I go
to the knowledge graph,
it has produced information
also for the entire capability.
So, you have a model to
take program by program
or for the entire capability.
Typically, if you have a
big job, which is running
and multiple programs in
it, multiple processes,
you would like to see such a view in terms
of bringing the entire intelligence out.
And finally, the third step in converting
it to a knowledge graph.
So, if you look at it, I've picked up one
of the programs which
are reverse engineered,
and it is showing me which
are the domain models
it has been associated with it.
I can double click on
functions, on the attributes,
on the information.
And, this is something that SME can use it
for a verification purposes, right?
So, essentially everything
that you saw earlier was the first agent.
This is where the information
comes to the second agent.
All information is put up as
part of the business process.
This was exactly the graph
that you saw earlier.
It's coming now in a
business as a workflow item.
And, I can leverage this, look at it
and start reimagining my application,
which is in the top section
out that you would see.
I can even pick up business rule-wise,
combine multiple business
rules and create a new rule.
So, we've given those
capabilities out there.
On the top, what you're seeing
is essentially nothing but,
and overall agile remodeling
of the application.
So, I'm completely re-imagining it.
It's not a lift and
shift model that we have.
I'm helping the BSA define
the epics, features, user stories.
And for every user story,
there is an assessment done on
the quality of the user story
through the invest score as well
as you have a prompt mechanism
by which you can generate
acceptance criterias,
generate a lot more information.
So, you see the Gherkin output over here.
We actually create BDD
at this point in time.
So, quality essentially starts
for us at this point in time.
This is the prompt where
I can generate information
in the form of...
If it doesn't meet my invest criteria,
I can further break it down
into many different rules.
So, I'm going to the third
agent in the interest of time.
From a third agent perspective,
now, my important part is to
re-architect or redesign it.
So, over here, what is needed
is three things, right?
Actually, two things.
One is a playbook about the steps
which we have to do in terms
of reverse engineering.
And, second is the
standards that I will use.
We've given both as an input
and I'll just show you how do we do this.
But it's started to
give me all information,
whether it's a logical model
or it's a physical model
or it's a sequence diagram
or it's an observability pattern
that has to be leveraged.
Everything which has been fed
as a standard is being
brought up by the agent,
which is Raina the third agent
that Anup spoke about, right?
So, the job of this particular agent
is to build the entire context
and make a prompt ready
for my next agent from a
development perspective.
So, if you look at it,
I'm generating right now,
I've fed the information that I need
to generate it using a
Java Flink model, okay?
I've just shown the step how
fast you can actually do it.
In the interest of time.
So, I'm trying to create a new design
and I'm giving to it the playbook as well
as the standards which have to be used.
I'm using data engineering architecture.
I'm giving the playbook
for these standards,
which is the Flink one.
And, I'm generating the entire context.
So, all information
pretty much gets generated
from that perspective.
Now, I'm going to my fourth agent,
which is the code generation agent.
Now, you know, this general,
this gets the entire information
and generates code from a Java Flink
architecture perspective.
What you essentially see is an example
of how this ran on the GPU
as well as it ran on the CPU.
So, there's a big distinct
difference in terms of the timing
that you would see if you run.
We've modeled it for
multiple sets of traits.
So, example, if I go from 20,000
trait to a 100,000 traits,
what will be the cost
from a CPU perspective
versus the GPU perspective?
And we help them to make a call from a job
by job perspective.
So, that was one I had to show.
Let's go back to the deck.
So, guys, this is what we have seen so far
from a results perspective.
We've achieved this as a
typical modernization program
with about 50 million lines of code takes
around seven years.
Okay? We've achieved
this kind of progress.
That infinity at the
end, guess what it is.
It is the fact that your entire
intelligence moves into data
and lives with you forever.
You'll never have a legacy,
right? That's the thing.
And this is kind of,
we kind of put together
how are we different from anybody else?
There are a lot of people
you'll get who move A to B,
but very few who will extract intelligence
and give you a state where you'll never
have a legacy anymore.
So, that's what we wanted to cover today-
- And, our agents have
actually run on DABstar,
so, you know, they scale
up pretty high on that.
So, we've constantly measuring it,
monitoring it from that perspective.
Thank you guys.
- Thank you, guys.
- That's all we had.
The time is up. Thank you.
- Thank you so much.